à 40 ans jean paré 35 sérieuse jolie
pourtant bien un athlète très bonne
femme d'intérieur
ce n'est pas un ami mais un mari qui
m'intéresserait si vous pouviez me
mettre en rapport avec une fille
d'origine agricole 2,26 à 36 ans pas
trop grande si possible je vous serais
très reconnaissant
si je cherche une fille d'origine
agricole c'est pour reprendre la place
de mes parents nous avons été très
surpris lors de l'arrivée des premières
lettres de ne trouver confronté à un
problème vraiment pathétique et c'est
pour cette raison que nous désirons
vraiment traiter cette affaire la foire
aux célibataires avec beaucoup de
sérieux le d'agriculteurs quel âge avez
vous j'ai 27 ans
vous n'êtes pas mariée encore comment ça
se fait ça c'est difficile à
l'agriculture vous savez le problème des
femmes dans l'agriculture assez
considérable l'élevage est assez
astreignant pour traire les vaches et
une femme aime bien son dimanche 70
alors que dans l'agriculture on n'est
pas libre
je suis content je suis en campagne là
je penserai marié je suis revenu en
campagne ça fait cinq ans j'avais déjà
32 ans puis arrivé ici je me perçois et
effi la campagne ne tiennent pas
tellement à se marier avec un gadin
campagne parce qu'elles veulent aller
plutôt vers la ville puisque paris si on
ne trouve même pas de travail du tout
pour des femmes ou très peu et puis ma
foi le temps passe j'ai 37 ans
aujourd'hui je ne suis pas marié je me
trouve assez bien comme ça le savez j'ai
22 ans et demi je me trouve très bien
comme ça et vous pensez de trouver l'âme
soeur à la foire aux célibataires bas à
peut-être je ne sais pas il semblerait
que je ne fis s'échappe plus facilement
de la terre pour d'autres métiers
il est exact que le travail à la terre
est un travail extrêmement difficile et
que lorsqu'une jeune fille peut épouser
quelqu'un qui n'est pas cultivateurs et
pour ses préférences vers cet autre
profession nous sommes des retraité
vosgien epinal nous nous plaisons
beaucoup nous sommes et nous avons comme
voisin de vieux garçon gaston et guy 38
et 36 ans très gentil cultivateurs aisée
probité absolue dont nous
nous portons garants pourriez-vous leur
faire parvenir une invitation à la foire
comment voyez-vous le mari d je me suis
pas posé la question
des qualités que vous aimeriez trouver
chez lui très un peu sonné jean petit
arrière
oui mais c est donc un lieu souhaité
riez vous le trouvez le milieu rural où
le milieu de la ville hosni
vous n'auriez pas souhaité vous marier
il ya quatre savons pas comment re on ne
prend pas d'apporter qui vous me coucher
tout ce que ça fait deux fois qu'on
n'aime pas et j étais pas marié était
trompé avant le mariage alors j'ai
abandonné
on n'avait pas pensé qu'on pouvait
trouver des hommes un peu meilleur que
celui qui vous avez trompés au nom n'est
pas chercher sedin au sérail de la ville
voudrait bien venir à la campagne elles
ne connaissent pas le métier difficile
et vous pensez qu'à la foire aux
célibataires vous allez trouver
l'heureux élu
je pense celui qui sait pas est
brouillée et il est souvent mieux seul
qu'elle ait déjà qu'une charles nicole à
rien quel apport mal qui n'y connaissent
pas grand chose
je me permet aujourd'hui de vous faire
part de notre candidature en espérant
trouver dans votre commune une épouse
ayant les mêmes affinités que votre
correspondant
la ville célibataire ce vote a eu lieu
la longue toujours faire sa vaisselle
préparer sa peau par les femmes seront
alors nous sommes bien capable de faire
c'est vrai difficile de faire autrement
celle du travail dgt à gaza pour vous
mon père s'est marié à 32 ans et ça n'a
pas empêché d'avoir 50 ans nourrit que
le problème de l'âge ne se pose pas il
ya des délégués on doit respecter quand
vous devez vous mariez bon bien cette
gare mais il faut penser 4 à 5 ans on
est encore célibataire qui a fait partie
des avoirs d'une il faut qu'on ait plus
qu à l'argus ça n'aurait plus le droit
de l'accès à beaucoup de place
vous y avez quand même à la foire de
vézelise catégorie avec l'espoir de
trouver quelqu'un on pas n'est ce pas
retrouver quelqu'un oui mais pas pour
peut-être pas pour le maya sûrement ça
vous a pas manqué quand même un homme
tout au long de votre vie
coucou aux projets bien précis qu'un
sachet blanc et si dieu verra